there's a war coming sam's brother this  spy game this is my world  careful careful when you get hurt  this is about time to mention this but i  don't drive  very naturally  we're family dom so i'll give you and  your crew the same deal you gave me  leave now you drive away  and you never come back ever  i ain't going anywhere little brother  you can't run  fast cars  y'all seen 10 second cards say hello to  the two-second call  impressive i know no that's that's not  impressive  [Music]  this should be interesting  i spent my entire life in your shadow  and now can you spend the rest of yours  we got the product we got the tools  living in mind we got the minds we got  the  little  juice  cars like this are eternal  [Music]  you take care of them and they'll run  forever  just like a family  [Music]  you build a right you take care of it  it'll live behind you  [Music]  it'll live forever  [Music]  you ready  [Applause]  [Music]  it's good to be back  you